what's going on there reject nation we made
it to the penultimate episode of all of us are
dead guys if you're here leave a like we very
much appreciate it helps on the algae read them
subscribe and click that notification bell to
get notified when our reaction for the finale
is up then handsome boys of prepper thanks
for helping us edit down these highlights
and of course you can find the full length
watch along by becoming a parajek today
check out all the content we have to
offer over our patreon let's do it
oh oh [ __ ] yes the will you'll go try something
don't don't leave you're the wrong guy
why would you talk that way
to him out of all people
oh wow what mercy
wow
why not go with him cause he's gonna
save every damn kid at the school
no [ __ ] no oh
you need to stop and shoot that guy
you know that yep don't be a hero
all of us are screwed
thank god for the net
freeze jurassic park
oh i was hoping my predictions were wrong aw crap
no you make sure he comes damn it no
no
ah no this is like kingdom all over again
oh it's amazing people sacrifice themselves
just to slow them down yep by a little time
faster
foreign
oh my god is he a special one
in the last couple episodes
i've given up so much hope for any more of those
oh my god are they foreshadowing this
come on chucks out you've lived this long
all right at the end buddy come
on i feel like this is foreign
oh no oh god give her some blood
oh that eye give her some blood
oh
let's do this it's time
go in there
oh
oh boy oh boy wow
she keeps getting knocked down
god it's like a highlight reel of
everyone we've lost oh there's shoes
even she didn't get lucky lucky hamby
oh my god it's the opening credits
archer him oh yeah come on now
ow ow
damn it oh you saw a [ __ ]
excellent timing
oh
no oh you better kiss her [ __ ] queen um
man
oh buddy
tyler cause you're going sick
oh [ __ ] i was hoping this
would not happen yeah hey
god
oh dude
but if he does become a hamby he can
just jump off the roof and join them
man she lost both of them today
oh damn
this [ __ ]
oh my god
what a plan oh my god what a plan
of course
me
no
oh
play through the pain
this show's being so mean
they hate us or something
order more drones
no more future for that college
yeah what an ironic name
wow wow wow oh my god
that's so much
oh wow oh wow oh my god oh my god
this is a really harsh episode
i quite no more cases damn how can you
sleep maybe he's gonna go kill himself
i really wonder i could
absolutely see that happening
there's wife there's daughter
there it is
here
it's good old korean dramas man bushels of fun
oh
take it away john keep it positive yes i am
just drained from the amount of fun we had
in this episode the amount of joy
and triumph over insurmountable odds
yeah this was definitely a feel-good
installment no uh this was you know it's funny
when this episode started i had gotten to the
point where i'd come in like a ironic way back
around on guinom because i was like ah this guy's
funny now i like this guy he's just got one track
mind he's not gonna ever stop and you got the
wrong emotions with him while i know but at
the same time it's like he's he's just always
looking for chong son he's always gonna fall
off something big and come back and find chong's
son again and uh yeah this episode brought it back
i felt like around the time that he reappeared and
really reconnected to you know actually getting
you know a chance at chung sun
everything else started to kind of
sink further and further as well and yeah like
this was a super uh emotionally heavy episode
and uh yeah it's like it's not the between them
it's not necessarily the like yeah you know like
you want to see you know i'm ripped apart or
exploded or something or other he's still alive
i i wonder if the both of them in some way might
still be alive just because again the the one one
of the couple elements i think you can rely on
is the uh cliffhanger to opening scene reversal
uh not necessarily that that's gonna be an all
good thing but i don't know i think if there's one
possible thing they might still have to to give
us a little bit of a reward i think maybe chong
son could become a hobby although i i don't know i
i have lost faith on it's funny ever ever since uh
namra you're like oh this could be it though maybe
everybody who gets bit has a chat but nah it just
hasn't happened so i'm not really expecting it but
i feel like there's still a a slight possibility
it could happen i think we're gonna get some type
of flash forward in the next episode oh this one
was really bleak this is the bleakest one yep the
darkest timeline for sure for sure uh we watched
this is the all of us are dead episode it is this
is literally a montage cutting around everyone
we've lost while the people that we're following
are about to be incinerated the only pride i have
is i called it you called it i called the
firefighter dad that's right give me my 200 yeah
you really called it they were not reunited for
five minutes eaten alive and i called chong son
you did you did i'm the predictor you are the
predict you are the king of the right who would
have been disappointed if they didn't you know
i think it would be better if they did my thing
all of us are greg yes man yeah um no i
just kept the i'm really i'm not i'm not
quite processing anything on an intellectual
level right now it's more just uh this void
yeah i'm a vessel for darkness at this moment yes
you're sucking in the light yeah no i feel you
it's it's it's the yeah it's the most
anguished it's the like there are no rewards
practically at all in this episode
and no they give you no catharsis
no catharsis i was like all right maybe [ __ ]
chong's son's gonna like grab one of them rebars
and like you know smash it into his skull yeah cut
his head off or cave it in or go through the brain
he gets bit he gets [ __ ] and then he gets his
eye gouged out and then he they go down in flames
like i i thought that chong's son uh would
have some type of little moment because
you know my mom was gone it's taken him a while to
turn but i don't care let him have his moment like
that's where my mind was at yeah i'm like they're
not giving him his moment if he part of me was
going oh they could've just done his original plan
i mean the plan they could have just done what he
just did there yeah but they didn't he didn't
know about the vacant pit that was a moment of
good good use of surroundings yeah so like if
they were aware of that he could have done that
originally yeah where he just like lured everyone
up there and then they all just fell but nope
nope no such luck getting into the whole school
you guys just stood there the whole time yeah
but eventually you just walk that's on top is
once every last zombie is in they've already
they've reached the height that he's had them
yeah he goes walking yeah but i mean that was
probably the closest the episode got i think to
giving a catharsis is when he gets to at least
uh at least say his piece and and you
know he's like i'm not afraid of you
you're still here just because you're afraid of of
you know the the the phone that's been long since
destroyed with the evidence of you killing the
principal you know like him getting to at least
uh tell him off one more time was rewarding in
and of itself i mean they've reached this point
in the show that i've often pondered if we did
live in a zombie apocalypse like would there be a
purpose in living would i just want to turn yeah
it's that age-old question of what's the age-old
question that our great-great-grandparents
have been asking if zombies took over but you
know i mean like yeah the the the innate
human instinct is to keep on surviving
but in a situation like this yeah the intellectual
uh weight to bear of that is like way advanced and
yeah i don't know well dude namra and stud muffin
that guy doesn't know what he's getting himself
into he does not she's not gonna be able to
control this forever you're not gonna be able
to guarantee that you can be fine if she bites you
and i mean if you do let her bite you there's no
guaranteeing she'll just like stop at the one and
not like actually eat you she's a good character
man she fought against her urges yeah and the
urge is almost one it's like that guy loves her
it's almost as if he's in love with her i mean
part of me is like dude you don't really know her
as well as you you think you should the matter
part is there's no one really around you know
in this hopeless existence now what if
you guys are incompatible i'm just saying
what if you find out that you don't
have anything in common you know
she's always that her music on what if you
guys don't connect over music or anything you
know clearly you were once a bully that's a way
different upbringing than her affluence you know
which for an extreme best guy do you think this
show has lost any sight of i mean was he a bully
was he just a fighter do you think this show has
lost any sight of its original themes i feel like
they haven't really carried that have they am i am
i missing it they see i felt like they were trying
to bring it back around when chong son was telling
guinom you know repeating that speech again of
like you might think you're all powerful but
you're really no different than you were before
yeah you're just trying to cover your ass and
he started crying greena yeah like you really
got cut to the core of guinom's real emotions yeah
yeah i don't know i mean i i part of me feels like
because this has been the development
of a situation i mean the themes
carry and i mean it comes back world's a bully
kind well yeah i mean i feel like there's there's
more to a lot of people yeah there's
the bullying theme and then the theme of
the appearances based bureaucracy that leads
to the mishandling of these types of events
and situations sure sure and uh yeah like
i felt like this is it's a bit more in that
side of the court to me at this point in the show
because you know like the the uh you know the
the leader of the the martial law commander you
know he has that exchange with the councilwoman
and you know things like that kind of brought me
back there but it does feel as though the themes
have kind of spread out from that initial state
and i mean two i feel like in the emotional beats
you get out of this there is like a mournful sort
of regret adult quality and i think that there
is a certain amount of just like interesting
humanity they use like i feel like sometimes
they're they're making like an overarching sort
of subtextual perhaps political comment and then
other times i feel like they're looking in on the
the gray areas of just being the human being who
has to carry these things out or who makes any
number of these decisions and what condition are
you under and because like i think the i think
this show is weirdly just a study of life yeah
yeah because it feels like it's just examining
what might happen on all these different scales
and and in all these different positions across
this one unifying scenario or anjo yeah poron joe
she lost a lot this episode yeah everyone around
her is being a hero today sacrificing themselves
they have some really really heartfelt
moments though like for for as much as
it's like you know heart-wrenching to be
like ugh they're only you know actualizing
their affections because of the situation
at hand but still those were lovely touching
moments and i mean to go back to the guy just
real quick the the martial luck commander like
i thought they did a nice job because at certain
times with that character you've been like whoa
it's a little extreme and then a lot of
other times you're like well i don't know
from your perspective it seems like you're
doing the best you can with a [ __ ] scenario
so this theme seemed the theme of today's
episode seemed to be about regret mm-hmm yeah
wish i told you then which side your hair
looked best on well even like with the
creator of the virus yeah yeah
and then marshall law commander
oh well pretty good [ __ ] happens right that's
right sometimes your experiment gets out of
control well even two i mean i i i liked by this
point too with the creator i i there were points
at which i was like okay that's a nifty exposition
device but i thought it was nice the way they've
interspersed that throughout the season where
you're kind of yeah you do learn about that guy's
journey in the past as the present unfolds you
know you learn about the first trial across the
expanding of like the the the real thing you know
a lot of real grace about it yeah it's fun stuff
man fun stuff dude yeah some hilarious jokes
in this episode some really good physical gags
another archer guy got the hit oh well we got one
more to go see you guys soon thanks for being here